and how old were you when you you missed
out on being in one of the most kind of
iconic dance videos of all time two
times that was happening there was
filming they were filming electric
Boogaloo breaking up the street from our
house at which is now Oscar De La Hoya's
gym in East LA and they come knocking on
my door to do to do Willy Willy Willy
they filming and moving up the street
wrong accent we need the filming a movie
about next neighborhood filming a movie
right there on arena willing like tell
your mom ma can I go shoot a minute well
what movie
there was the shooter move you ain't
[ __ ] you know movie come on it's break
dancing you ain't got a little business
break no dancing how come I can't be in
it she's like what you're gonna sit your
butt over here on this couch there's a
summer break maybe I had D's on my
report card or something yeah
and then maybe the you know a year later
or the year before at a different time
at a different job they come knocking on
my door the same person doo-doo-doo
Deborah Deborah they Michael Jackson's
no video shooting drilling in the
alleyways oh no because we in the
projects is here and buy every projects
are like factories yeah so over by the
alleys and the factories Michael Jackson
was shooting thriller and I was like ma
come on please MA can I go what you
ain't goin in no alley with no Michael
Jackson
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you